the last four years we started to become
close the last four years of the eight
year run
first one and then since then we've
literally uh our brothers
john stamos brought bob saget's
signature sense of humor to his memorial
service last friday the actor's full
tribute which was published by the los
angeles times was heartfelt but it was
also largely inspired by bob's raunchier
side they say the measure of a man is
judged by the company he keeps
john says quote when we were together we
were like an old married couple all
bickering no sex
personally i hope to die after a
beautiful night of lovemaking with my
wife but i'm glad bob didn't go that way
as i said i rather he dies after doing
what he did best sorry kelly that's the
kind of joke bob loved you can't always
override with comedy when it really hits
you but
gallows humor is where i go
and that's how i survive
john's speech was also full of sweet
moments including a story he told about
asking the universe for a sign shortly
after bob's death quote all of a sudden
a tiny hummingbird came fluttering down
from above and landed on a tree right in
front of me john even shared proof of
the magic moment on instagram
hummingbirds have special meaning to
john he says they've always symbolized
his late parents and this one was his
mom telling him bob is okay when you
care about somebody
especially now i'm finding you got to
let them know john emotionally ends his
speech quote bob i will never ever have
another friend like you you will always
be my best friend you are my new
guardian angel a guardian angel with the
dirtiest mouth and a heart as big and
benevolent as forever i love this man
many full house co-stars attended bob's
funeral along with several friends and
family members like bob's wife kelly
rizzo his
constant message was
just treat everybody with kindness
he was just
sorry he was just such a
he was just the best man i've ever known
in my life
on thursday kelly emotionally opened up
to hoda cotby on the today show her
first tv interview since bob's death
because you know he'd gone through so
much in his life and he knew how hard
life could be
and so he always was just so kind
and loving to everybody
and
he was just
sorry he was just such a
he was just the best man i've ever known
in my life
and he was just so kind and so wonderful
and everybody that was in his life knew
it
and even anybody that would just
casually meet him was like wow this is a
special guy
ahead of their 2018 nuptials the travel
blogger shared the same sentiments to
e.t about her late husband he's just the
most pure heart ever and he
treats me like a princess and
you know even though i don't want the
princess gown i want the guy that treats
me like a princess and he does he's just
so wonderful so fun you know being with
the comedian has its challenges they're
like oh you must be laughing all the
time i'm like
not all the time easy they're serious
very dark right right but you know it's
it's
it's still a blast and he's just
wonderful and you know even though
um
you know he's got a couple years on me
he i'm like usually the adult in the
relationship you know
it's really it's really funny